unas elecciones marcadas por la
fragmentación del voto con la imposición
de los socialdemócratas sobre la unión
conservadora empiezan las coaliciones
para una mayor presencia en la cámara de
diputados- el spd que tendría la
posibilidad de posicionar a olaf scholz
como canciller socialdemócrata ha
manifestado su preferencia por asociarse
con los verdes y el partido liberal fdp
sin embargo lfp naturaleza más
conservadora prefiere no tomar una
decisión tan apresurada alemania quiere
tener un gobierno de centro es un claro
rechazo a una coalición entre el spd los
verdes y la izquierda de este modo
alemania sigue siendo un socio fiable en
la escena internacional dentro de las
hipótesis nunca antes se había hablado
de una coalición entre el spd los verdes
y la izquierda- una asociación que
aunque parece poco probable no ha sido
descartada por el spd por su parte los
conservadores del cdu csv afrontan su
peor resultado desde la segunda guerra
mundial y ahora buscan construir un
gobierno liderado por ellos ahora se
trata de promover una alianza de
gobierno resistente en el diálogo de los
demócratas una coalición de la cdu el
fdp
sería una verdadera coalición para el
futuro para la modernización la
sostenibilidad y la estabilidad con el
actual panorama y según el esquema de
pactos de alemania existen varias
alianzas posibles inicia la difícil
tarea de acordar un gobierno entre al
menos tres partidos un juego de
negociaciones que según expertos
tardaría hasta mediados de diciembre